Less than a month after it was reported that
Academy Award-nominated actor Jonah Hill was
lined up to star alongside Robert Pattinson
in The Batman, Deadline has dropped a bombshell:
Hill is no longer in talks for the movie.
Hill, originally known for roles in raunchy
comedies, took his career to new heights with
his astounding performances in The Wolf of
Wall Street and the Netflix series Maniac,
was reportedly being courted to portray a
villain in the Matt Reeves-directed film.
Though Warner Bros. gave no explicit confirmation,
outlets widely claimed that Hill would play
either the Riddler or Penguin opposite Pattinson's
Bruce Wayne.
Sources close to Deadline with knowledge of
the situation have indicated that talks broke
down between Hill and the powers that be at
Warner Bros.
But why exactly did those conversations stop?
It's looking like the split was a mutual decision,
and it may have at least partially been over
money.
Per The Hollywood Reporter, Hill and Warner
Bros. simply couldn't, quote, "come to terms
on a deal" language that hints that contractual
negotiations may have been the meat of the
talks between the actor and the studio.
Hill passing on The Batman, or Warner Bros.
executives telling him things just weren't
going to work out, may actually have been
weeks in the making.
Variety reporter Justin Kroll indicated in
a now-deleted tweet on September 25, 2019
exactly three weeks before Deadline's new
report that Hill was sitting on the offer
for The Batman "for over a month" and that
money was a "bargaining point" in conversations
with Warner Bros.
According to Kroll's sources, Hill reportedly
wanted $10 million more than double what Pattinson
is making for actually leading the film.
"Uh, don't forget about my money."
These claims haven't been corroborated, but
this wasn't coming from some rumor site.
It's Variety.
Kroll also noted that Hill and Warner Bros.
may have been torn between the two roles,
unable to decide whether he'd star as the
Riddler or Penguin, but it seems more likely
that money was the biggest motivating factor.
"If you're good at something, never do it
for free."
Even without Hill, The Batman has some serious
star power attached to it.
Reeves, who's known for directing the original
Cloverfield, the horror remake Let Me In,
and the sequels Dawn of the Planet of the
Apes and War for the Planet of the Apes, is
at the helm.
Pattinson, who has become something of an
indie movie king and has long since shed the
weight of his breakout role in the Twilight
film franchise, is the title star.
Jeffrey Wright will play Commissioner Gordon
and newly added actress Zoë Kravitz will
dig her claws into Catwoman.
Even without Hill on board, The Batman is
packing major heat, and Warner Bros. is already
looking to find someone just as talented as
Hill to add even further star power.
The studio is said to now be looking at new
candidates to portray either the Riddler or
Penguin in The Batman, and as for who those
lucky actors might be, there have been some
rumblings about Seth Rogen another funny guy
often linked to Hill, who has been breaking
ever more into fresher territory potentially
stepping up.
However, Deadline notes that there was only
ever interest in Rogen for one of the two
roles, with no offers or talks yet occurring.
If Warner Bros. executives had their sights
set on Hill for either of the two iconic DC
Comics villains, then it stands to reason
that the studio will probably go with someone
else like him: a comedic actor who has proven
capable of bringing nuanced, delightful performances
to more dramatic fare.
And he can also be threatening:
"Bang bang!"
"Jesus!
Please put it down!"
"Oh f---!"
"Bang!
Bang!
You're dead!"
It seems that's a trend with the Batman casting,
going with an unexpected choice for a major
role.
Pattinson wasn't an obvious pick for Batman,
and neither was Hill for the Riddler or Penguin.
Wright may also have been a surprise pick
for some as Commissioner Gordon.
And though Kravitz has played Catwoman before,
voicing the antiheroine in The Lego Batman
Movie...
"Catwoman!"
"Meow meow, you're in!
Meow Meow."
...her casting likewise raised some eyebrows.
In related news, Warner Bros. has cast Paul
Dano as The Riddler alongside Pattinson's
Batman, according to The Hollywood Reporter.
You might recognize Dano from his stellar
accolades in movies like There Will Be Blood,
12 Years a Slave, Prisoners, and Swiss Army
Man.
The Batman will crusade into theaters without
Jonah Hill on June 25, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Batman
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.